clark county credit union the sponsors
of this next segment is breaking down
three smart things to do with the home
equity line of credit take a look
hey jennifer welcome back
hi thanks for having me absolutely so
last time you were here we talked about
real estate so let's do that again let's
remind people how they can get money out
of their homes and use it for other
things
right so with the increase in value that
we're seeing in the homes in the valley
and probably nationwide
so homeowners are
accruing equity
at a record pace so it's a great
opportunity to get a home equity line of
credit
you can borrow against the equity in
your home pay off high interest rate
debt uh do some home
uh improvements or renovations
um pay for
uh
children's college tuition really
anything goes as far as purpose goes but
because the equity has increased so much
it is a much cheaper way
to um
pay off your debt
right that's music to people's ears
right and
with this larger amount of money that
they have you know what are the projects
that they're using it for
so we're going to be here in vegas
yes we're seeing a lot all summer long
members of clark county credit union
have been borrowing against the equity
of their home to put in pools lots of
swimming pools backyards
we've done casitas uh mother-in-law
quarters i have personally done a helac
for one of our members for raiders
tickets wow
my husband and i borrowed against our
equity to build a workshop on the side
of the house so
lots of home improvements mostly
swimming pools but really i've done a
lot of debt consolidation as well
so that's a very smart way to
consolidate high interest rate debt into
one payment at a much lower rate of
interest clearly all of this needs
careful examination and preparation and
help from you guys um so what other
debts would you
consider would you tell your consumers
to consolidate with the heloc so with
the holidays coming up this is a great
opportunity if you do use your credit
cards for holiday shopping to
consolidate those into one payment using
a home equity line of credit also tax
time is coming and if you owe the irs
money it is much cheaper to use a home
equity line to pay them often to use
their interest rate and fees and that
they charge oh smart smart so how can we
get more information from you guys
so they can just call us uh clark county
credit union apply online at ccculv.org
or give us a call any member of the home
equity team would love to help
thank you clark county credit union for
sponsoring this segment for more
information like she said call
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org mercedes